Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala says in the
200th and final verse of Surat Ali
Imran.
Asbiru
Wasabiru
Warabitu
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala says,
All you who have believed,
be patient
and
be more patient than your enemies that
stand against you
and
do what is called ribat.
Now, ribat in the Arabic language is
originally taken from al-rabt,
which is a rope
as you use to tie two things together.
And so, it becomes
the
term that is used to articulate
preparation
for war.
It's referred to as ribat. Why? Because
you know, one of the most
one of the most prominent aspects of war
are horses.
And horses, you know, are used
they're tied with ropes. I think we can
see the connection. So, it's referred to
as a ribat.
And so, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala here
in this verse is saying, "Be patient,
sabiru,
which means to be more patient than your
enemy,
warabitu,
and
you know, prepare yourselves for battle.
Be in a constant state of readiness
to face your enemies on the
battlefield."
Now,
there's an interesting narration,
you know, whenever someone hears this
verse and hears this term,
aribat, warabitu, right? Allah uses this
term, surat al-anfal, wa'iddulu huma
stata'tum min quwatin wamin
ribat al-khail, right? So, whenever
someone hears this term, immediately
what comes to mind is war, and you know,
a person having his
having himself in order and ready at a
moment's notice to
defend and fight on the battlefield.
And so, that's clear. That's clear to
everyone who hears the verse.
But, there's another aspect of this
verse, of this word, aribat,
that is not so obvious.
And so, what does the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam do?
He points out
the meaning of the verse that is less
obvious.
Right? Everyone gets the obvious one.
So, he now wishes to add to the verse
and complement it by pointing out an
aspect of the verse that not many will
think of.
There's a narration collected by Imam
Malik in his book Al-Muwatta and both
Bukhari and Muslim on the authority of
Abu Hurairah
that the prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam said to the companions
He said to the companions,
"Shall I not inform you
of that which Allah
uses most to
erase
bad deeds, erase sins, and raise
levels?"
Many of us believe
on incorrectly
that paradise is earned most usually by
way of big giant sacrifices,
huge
choices that are of epic proportion,
one
fork in the road, if you will, that a
person makes the right choice at this
moment and you know, it it it
changes everything. It's this epic
sacrifice.
This is not how most people enter
paradise.
Most people will enter paradise
due to very mundane, overlooked
deeds that most people wouldn't bat an
eye at.
Little deeds that are done repeatedly,
systematically,
that are done
habitually,
and they accumulate
and build a person's momentum
through the gates of paradise.
So, in this narration, the prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam says, "Shall
I not inform you of that which Allah
uses to erase from a person's sin and
raise
a person's levels
and and and status?"
Meaning it's it's the way that he says
it, it's as if this is the only way that
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala does this.
Obviously, there are many ways that
Allah forgives sins and raises levels,
but this is
one of the most common and one of the
most likely. The companion said, "Bala,
of course."
He said,
[Silence]
He says,
"Perfecting one's wudu
even in times of discomfort. The water
is cold or it's cold outside or the
water's hot or warm and it's hot outside
that a person doesn't cut corners even
then. They
completely make their wudu
even in times of discomfort.
He says, "And
making one's steps to the masjid
very numerous.
Constantly going to and fro
salat and the masjid.
He says,
"And waiting for a prayer
after you've already finished a prayer."
Meaning once you go to the masjid, you
make salat al-maghrib, and then you
remain in the masjid waiting for salat
al-isha. This one
thing here that many of us would not
even really
think about or consider to be something
that would be life-altering,
these are the three things that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala most usually
forgives or erases sins, which is better
than
which is a higher status than just
forgiveness.
Forgiveness, the sin is affirmed, but he
overlooks it.
Erasure of the sin means that the sin is
completely removed as if it never
happened.
The prophet here says,
"That Allah doesn't just forgive the
sins by these
acts of worship, he completely erases
them."
As if they never happened.
He says,
"That is truly ribat. That is ribat."
Now,
if we take this narration, obviously
when the companions heard this,
what is the first verse that would come
to mind? This verse in Surat Ali Imran,
right?
It's got a key word in it that
causes the listener to make an
association between what he's saying and
this verse, and that's how it is
intended. It was meant that. That's
why he said it that.
So, we take this narration, and it
brings out another dimension
of the meaning of the ribat that most
people would not really
would not really pay attention to or
would not really
would not realize, if you will.
And so, in this way, he
complements the verse and
enriches the listeners'
understanding of the verse.
Nasa Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
an
yaj'alana mimman yastami'unal qawla
fayattabi'una ahsanah. As'aluhu
subhanahu wa ta'ala an yarzuqana
isbaghal wudu' 'alal makarih wa an
yarzuqana kathratul khuta ilal masajidi
wa an
yakhtarana wa an yastafiyana
lintizaris salawati ba'das salah.
[Arabic recitation]